.
>> THERE IS SOMETHING ELSE THAT
IS POPPED UP THIS AFTERNOON THA
WE WANT TO COVER.
NEW YORK GOVERNOR TO THAT WAS
EXTOLLED EARLIER THIS WEEK
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT NEARLY 12,00
MORE COVERT DEATHS IN NEW YORK
STATE THAN THE CUOMO
ADMINISTRATION HAD PUBLICIZED.
LET'S BRING IN JANICE DEAN ON
THE PHONE.
DENNIS, THE NUMBERS WERE 43,400
IT'S NOW 55,395 WITH THE
ADDITION OF THESE 12,000 DEATHS.
APPARENTLY THESE ARE NOT ONLY
CONFIRMED COVID DEATHS, BUT
PRESUMED COVID DEATHS AS WELL.
WHAT YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> THIS IS NOT NEW INFORMATION
THE FEDERAL HEALTH OFFICIALS
HAVE BEEN USING THE HIGHER TALL
FOR MANY MONTHS IN NEW YORK, BU
GOVERNOR CUOMO HAS BEEN SORT OF
FUDGING THE NUMBERS FROM THE
BEGINNING INCLUDING WITH NURSIN
HOMES.
ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I'VE BEE
SO OUTSPOKEN IS BECAUSE HE DID
NOT COUNT THOSE THAT DIED IN TH
HOSPITAL LIKE MY MOTHER-IN-LAW,
SHE CONTRACTED COVID AND HER
ASSISTED LIVING RESIDENCE.
SHE DIED IN THE HOSPITAL IN HER
NUMBERS DIDN'T COUNT.
THE NEW GOVERNOR HAS DECIDED TO
BECOME TRANSPARENT.
SHE SAID I'M GOING TO REPORT TH
NUMBERS DOES RATHER THAN THE
ONES THE OTHER GUY WANTS YOU TO
THINK THEY ARE.
>> IT'S BRUTAL, JANET.
IT ALMOST WARRANTS THERE ARE
PRESUMED IN CONFIRMED DEATHS.
SHE SAID THE PUBLIC DESERVES A
CLEAR HONEST PICTURE OF WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
THERE IS SO MUCH ABOUT THIS
STORY THAT WE KNOW YOU IN YOUR
FAMILY HAS BEEN SO GREATLY
AFFECTED BY ALL OF THIS VARIES
ARE YOU HOPEFUL THAT SHE WILL
LEAD US TO A BETTER PLACE IN AL
OF THIS?
>> I'M GOING TO GIVE HER A FEW
DAYS.
I'M GOING TO GIVE HER A LITTLE
BIT OF TIME, BUT I'M ALREADY
DISTURBED BY THE FACT THAT SHE
STILL HAS HOWARD ZUCKER ON THE
PAYROLL, HE IS THE HEALTH
COMMISSIONER HE'S ALSO THE
AUTHOR OF THE MARCH 25TH MANDAT
FOR PUTTING COVID POSITIVE
PATIENTS IN A NURSING HOME FOR
IT HE ALSO HELPED COVER UP THOS
NUMBERS SO THE FACT THAT HE IS
STILL AROUND AND HE IS REALLY
GUY THAT HAND-IN-HAND WITH
GOVERNOR CUOMO TO MISLEAD US ON
COVID DEATHS.
SO SHE REALLY NEEDS TO CLEAN
HOUSE.
SHE SAYS SHE'S GOING TO DO THAT
BUT IF I'M GOING TO BELIEVE HER
SHE HAS TO GET RID OF THE NUMBE
ONE OR THE NUMBER TWO GUY IN
THAT IS HER HEALTH COMMISSIONER.
>> WE KNOW FROM PREVIOUS NEW
YORK STATE OFFICIALS THAT ANDRE
CUOMO ALLEGEDLY UNDERCOUNTED
NURSING HOME DEATHS BY 50
PERCENT OR MAY BE A LITTLE
BIT MORE THAN THAT AGAIN, THE
ADDITIONAL DESK HERE, THE 12,00
RELEASED BY THE NEW GOVERNOR DO
NOT APPEAR TO BE ADDITIONAL
NURSING HOME DEATHS, BUT JANICE
YOU'RE MAKING THE POINT HERE
THAT EVEN THOUGH THEY MAY NOT B
LISTED IS NURSING HOME DEATHS,
PEOPLE FROM NURSING HOMES WHO
WENT SOMEWHERE ELSE LIKE A
HOSPITAL IN DIED COULD BE
INCLUDED IN THIS ACCOUNT SO
THEREFORE THIS COULD UP THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT CONTRACTE
COVID IN NURSING HOME AND SO
SPECIFICALLY PASSED AWAY.
>> CORRECT, BUT WE NEED THE
INVESTIGATION TO CONTINUE.
THE ONE THING I WANT TO MAKE
PEOPLE REMEMBER IS THAT THERE
ARE ONGOING INVESTIGATIONS HERE
IN NEW YORK ABOUT THE NURSING
HOMES.
NOT ONLY THE LYING ABOUT THE
DEATH TOLL, BUT THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS THAT THE
GOVERNOR DID, HE GAVE NURSING
HOMES LINKAGE IMMUNITY SO NO ON
COULD SUE THEM.
THERE ARE MANY THINGS THAT THIS
GOVERNOR HAS TO BE INVESTIGATED
FOR, AND I WANT THAT, BUT THIS
NEW NUMBER OF THE 12,000, I WAN
A FEDERAL PROBE INTO THIS.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION DECIDE
NOT TO GO AHEAD WITH THE DOJ
INVESTIGATION NOT ONLY DID THEY
INVESTIGATE GOVERNOR CUOMO, BUT
THE OTHER GOVERNORS WHO PUT
COVID POSITIVE PATIENTS IN THE
NURSING HOME FOR THERE SEEMS TO
BE A LOT OF COVERING UP THAT I
THINK NEEDS TO BE LOOKED AT MOR
CLOSELY.
>> A REAL QUICK FINAL QUESTION
AS WE'VE GOT BENJAMIN WHO HAVE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME JANICE, HOW
ARE YOU DOING.
OBVIOUSLY, WE HAVE ALL WATCHED
YOU SO CLOSELY THROUGHOUT THIS
AND NOW THAT HE IS GONE FROM TH
MANSION, THERE WAS THE DEBACLE
WITH THE DOG, HOW ARE YOU DOING?
>> LISTEN, PEOPLE THINK THIS IS
SOMEWHAT OF A VICTORY.
I'VE BEEN SCREAMING FOR A YEAR
IN A HALF NOW THAT THIS GOVERNO
IS CORRUPT IN I THINK HE'S
CRIMINAL P RATE I THINK A LOT O
THESE CHARGES THAT ARE GOING TO
BE FORTHCOMING ARE GOING TO BE
CRIMINAL VERY A LOT OF PEOPLE
THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF
JUSTIFICATION, BUT I AM GOING T
HOLD HER ACCOUNTABLE AS WELL, I
SHE'S NOT FORTHCOMING AND
TRANSPARENT AND IF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS, I'M GOING TO
SCREAM JUST AS LOUD AS I DID
WITH THE PREVIOUS GUY.
>> JANICE, WE APPRECIATE YOU.
>> JANICE, THANKS SO MUCH